because I first of all the different
vision that you'd be at a tech festival
talking about yourself no no I did not
that was not ever part of the plan but
I'm very happy to be here what was it
like out there I mean obviously you're
used to performing but you know speaking
in front of a crowd like that as
receptive as they are as receptive as
they can be wasn't experience like for
you it was fun public speaking is always
something I've struggled with a little
bit as a dancer you're kind of taught to
be seen and not heard
right and you express yourself with your
body so it's I was never growing up it
was never something I was taught to
speak in public really yeah so that was
always a little bit hard but the older I
get the easier it gets the more I do it
the easier it gets so it was fun and I
enjoyed it I loved the conversation with
Dallas it was very easy and we were
friends so it was easy to talk to him
another another thing for you to conquer
in your evolution I knows right when you
think back to you know way before you
went on this journey like and you see
where you are now
are you feel like you're living your
dream oh absolutely I mean this was
literally what I've been dreaming about
for almost a decade being on the show
and then having the spin-off of the show
and being able to be a part of that and
being the first drag queen and her story
to get their own spin-off from RuPaul's
Drag Race is like incredible I'm
definitely living my dreams and getting
the blessing from the Petersons yes
exactly so you know you have been and
continue to be a role model for so many
people I'm sure since the first moment
they saw you on camera on screen are you
comfortable with that idea of being role
model I mean it definitely comes with a
lot of pressure like I'm not perfect I
make mistakes I or can I say that yeah
I'm not perfect so um I try to I try to
just be as human as possible and own my
mistakes and kind of my life and I think
that's the best way to be a role model
yeah any better so an example that way
cuz everybody goes through it right yeah
when you think about Season eleven do
you have any favorite moments that come
to mind favorite moments for me I really
enjoyed doing the Improv challenge when
I was a new
but I love that one um I had a lot of
fun than any of the dance challenges
we're always great I loved every single
runway I got to do I just had a blast
yeah and runways were probably my
favorite part of the whole thing mm-hmm
yeah so you know people going into this
new competition right that you're gonna
be doing or judging garnishes yeah what
will you be looking for and if you're
gonna give anyone advice on how they can
excel what would you say
I'm looking for charisma uniqueness
nerve and talent of course of course I
always say I'm just looking for that
indescribable Janice I caught that spark
that somebody has that you can't teach
that um that superstar quality yeah
that's what I'm looking for I'm looking
to laugh I'm looking to cry I'm looking
to be knocked off my chair yeah and the
best advice I can give somebody is just
go balls to the walls you have to go in
full force you can't hold anything back
this is your moment yeah and you have to
just leave it all on that camera when
did you know that you've had that
superstar quality was that something
that you knew you had from a very young
age no I never really thought I had it I
mean I never ill I was like oh my god
I'm a superstar I just always kind of
went out and did the best I could I
don't think it's a weird thing to like
think of yourself in that way I feel
like right right in my opinion anyway
for me so but is that I mean now that
you're here yeah and you know you said
that that's what you're looking for for
that superstar quality when you think
about yourself now you think about
yourself having the superstar quality
yes it's so like a weird thing good like
I don't know I don't know what it is I
just people seem to like me so yeah I'm
very thankful for that what is it about
this show in this franchise now that you
think people are really drawn to I think
it's great I just think it there's a lot
of people out there who have felt unseen
for a long time and this kind of they
see themselves in the Queens and the
girls and I think it's cool because also
it helps humanize drag queens I think
drag queens are often seen as like
clowns or freaks are these weird
outcasts of society but we're just human
beings like everyone else with a story
to tell and that's one of the most
beautiful things about drag race is it
humanizes us for people they see our
hearts and they see our
and our backstories and they're like oh
wow that's a person yeah so I think
that's part of the reason it's become so
popular and hopefully opens the door to
other stories and maybe other programs
as well exactly
and we're fierce so what do you think is
lacking in media when it comes to LGBTQ
plus representation oh my goodness
what's lacking I mean I would just love
to see more of it I think we've made
such strides recently in representation
in media with shows like I love the the
reboot of queer I and pose that amazing
transgender cast and I think there's a I
feel like there's a lot of
representation for the LGBT community I
would love to see more transact hrus
and actors and rules especially trans
male actors I don't see a lot of that so
I think that's something we could kind
of boost up yeah cuz I feel like there's
a there's a lot of everything else there
could always be more so I would love to
see more of everything but I would like
definitely love to see the the trans
folk get a little bit more of a
spotlight what else is coming up for you
when you think there's more people like
camera more elevation and you're the
spot now where you are kind of at the
top of that for a lot of people I am um
I'm working on a one-woman show that
I'll be doing in the UK in December so
that's exciting
and then just lots of traveling and
going to Africa in a month
musics perform South Africa and then I
think we have a South America tour
planned in the new year and we're
working on an Asia tour as well so we're
cons you know Brooklyn Heights world
domination yeah amazing you'll get it
yeah and I would love to work more in TV
I really am finding that I'm enjoying
one of the cool things about this whole
experience is that I'm discovering new
things that I like to do yeah I'm just
covering I like doing TV it's really fun
so I would love to do more TV stuff I'd
love to do more stage acting just really
anything like I said earlier I'm saying
yes to everything yeah I just want to
try everything's well I like TV clearly
TV likes you know so ya know see more I
hope so thank you thank you so much